on
bonjour à tous si vous nous rejoignez à
une semaine du premier tour des
élections régionales france 3 bourgogne
et france 3 franche comté bouleverse
leur programme nous vous proposons trois
débats thématiques tout au long du
week-end pour mieux comprendre les
enjeux de ce scrutin après les
transports ce matin et avant le
développement économique demain on va
parler d'environnement et de politique
écologique aujourd'hui au niveau
régional avec vous eric sicaud et avec
nos invités sur le plateau
oui et comme ce matin et comme demain
nous avons réuni 6 invité sur ce plateau
pour ce débat consacré à l'environnement
benoît bordât bonjour pour la liste ps
de marie-guite dufay vous êtes
conseiller municipal à dijon délégué
régional de 4,21 en bourgogne le parti
de corinne lepage
patrick jean bonjour jour la liste elle
est arrivée de françois sauvadet vous
êtes maire divers droite de pontarlier
dans le doubs françois lotteau bonjour
pour la liste europe écologie les verts
de cécile prud'hommes vous êtes le
délégué régional d'europe écologie les
verts en bourgogne
julien houle bonjour jours pour la liste
fn menée par sophie montel vous êtes
secrétaire départemental du front
national dans l'yonne
sophie nicolet pour la liste du modem de
christophe grudler de la chef de file en
saône-et-loire et puis gérard lacroix
bonjour vous êtes la tête de liste de la
hutte mené par julien bon élève
l'alliance écologiste indépendante vous
était de liste dans le jura alors vous
en avez l'habitude c'est eh oui cette
émission c'est aussi à la vôtre vous
pouvez l'a commentée sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le mot dias qui va
s'afficher reg bfcc simple règle comme
régional bfc comme bourgogne franche
comté notre future nouvelle grande
région alors c'est demain que s'ouvre à
à paris la coop 21 la conférence
internationale sur le climat à l'heure à
la veille de cet événement nous allons
justement parler de transition
écologique de transition énergétique et
parmi les compétences et effectivement
les futures régions vos devoirs
coordonner l'action des collectivités
dans l'aménagement durable la
biodiversité le climat la qualité de
l'air et l'énergie alors avant de parler
énergies dans la seconde partie de ce
débat d'abord un peu parler d'économie
chacun se demande un peu comment
concilier développement économique dans
nos régions et respect
de la nature respect de l'environnement
la première question est ce qu'il faut
réorienter toutes les aides du conseil
régional et notamment en s'adressant
prioritairement aux entreprises qui
jouent le jeu de la transition
écologique commence aujourd'hui on a
déjà commencé en bourgogne franche comté
à faire la transition écologique la
transition énergétique pour l'économie
puisque on s'est fixé un certain nombre
d'objectifs avec la région bourgogne
avec la région franche comté et c'est
dans notre programme c'est de diminuer
les gaz à émission de serre c'est de
diminuer la consommation énergétique
finale des foyers et aujourd'hui on le
voit avec le développement des cluster
éolien des énergies renouvelables on a
une forme un formidable outil pour faire
des leviers économiques et aujourd'hui
l'enjeu c'est à la fois de s'appuyer sur
nos entreprises qui sont déjà
développées sur ces énergies là est à la
fois de produire notre propre énergie et
aussi de diminuer la facture énergétique
des foyers puisqu'aujourd'hui les foyers
ils regardent et garde à la fin du mois
ce qui paye ça on va y revenir dans la
deuxième partie de l'émission
monsieur jean louis blanc je crois que
tout d'abord la préoccupation
environnementale n'est la propriété
personnes plutôt de tout le monde donc
nous sommes bientôt non engagé fermement
dans cette décence de l'environnement
mais dans une défense de leurs vivement
une préservation environnement qui soit
- punitif que précédemment
c'est à dire faire véritablement du
développement responsable et durable un
levier développement économique
c'est-à-dire allier à la fois la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre de
préserver l'activité économique de
dynamisme économique agricole
touristique et autres mais en même temps
de prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
préserver le futur
c'est tout l'enjeu et c'est donc
l'objectif c'est de passer de 7 de ce
dogme qui nous a dirigé pendant à cette
rude année contraignant à milan les
essais team local pour contraire passer
vers un soutien à la préservation de
l'environnement mais en permettant le
développement économique c'est tout
l'enjeu de cette élection
l'écologie est forcément punitif selon
prétendre que la poursuite des
politiques actuelles qui sont menées
depuis une vingtaine d'années une spa de
manière ininterrompue va nous permettre
d'aller bien loin je pense d'une vision
totale pour ma part j'ai toujours abordé
les questions environnementales par
l'économie
à l'heure actuelle les ce qu'on nous
présente comme des solutions
productiviste d'être productive
sous prétexte qu'elles sont prônées
s'appelle productiviste ne sont
absolument pas la meilleure preuve c'est
qu'il suffit que les subversions
disparaisse pour que tout ça s'arrête
n'est ce pas le système qui est mis en
place à l'heure actuelle est un système
qui est tout à fait constitutionnelle
puisqu'il s'agit d'un signe ce qu'on
appelle d'une principe du pollueur
subventionner le seul principe
constitutionnel et nous le devons à
monsieur chirac n'est ce pas dans le
cadre de la charte conseil
constitutionnel de l'environnement c'est
le principe du pollueur payeur
parce que prétendre comme le fait la
région où comme l'ont fait tous les
partis qui se sont succédé à la tête de
l'otan'' de l'état depuis 1976 qu'on va
poursuivre la croissance à crédit c'est
pas puisque l'état est en faillite c'est
pas moi qui dis c'est monsieur fillon
et bien c'est une illusion totale n'est
ce pas ce qu'il faut c'est arrivé en
revenir aux principes fondamentaux qui
existent de la constitution le principe
de liberté
le principe d'égalité il n'y a pas de
principes de fraternité
sauf celui qui est inscrit sur les
messieurs le principe important c'est le
principe de sécurité qui ne s'applique
pas c'est pas seulement la sécurité
publique mais également la sécurité
alimentaire la sécurité environnementale
la sécurité et hospitalières n'est ce
pas et tout cela ne suppose absolument
pas de financements publics ça suppose
simplement que les acteurs économiques
jouent sans discrimination telles que
celles qui sont organisées par l'union
européenne françois lotteau wima goûter
faire un petit un peu de ça ça ne marche
pas patry gens parler de viol comme un
bien sûr mais justement je vais dire que
les dogues mais ça marche pas non plus
ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre et faire
un peu de soutien de 6 vers dire une
chose et puis en même temps faire le
contraire ça ne fonctionne pas il faut
voir des choses concrètes
je vais citer qu'un chiffre investir 1
million d'euros permet de créer 19
emplois dans l'efficacité énergétique
quatorze emplois dans les renouvelables
alors que ça ne permet d'en créer que 5
dans le charbon nucléaire
voilà c'est c'est simple voilà le sens
dans lequel il faut aller il faut pas
continuer de piller les ressources
naturelles
il faut créer les emplois dans les
directions là où quatre hommes en oeuvre
dans votre parti participe aux deux
exécutifs sortants est ce que vous
considérez que les régions ont fait leur
travail de ce point de vue là où est ce
que vous êtes critique par rapport au
bilan
les régions ont fait un peu mais pas
assez et un peu de manière
contradictoire on peut pas mettre un peu
d'argent dans une chose beaucoup dans
l'autre et ensuite faire surtout de
l'affichage sur le côté ou un ami qu'un
peu julian d'où l'on entend peu le front
national sur ce thème de l'environnement
du développement durable et à l'entente
qui vous préoccupe bien sûr qui me
préoccupe la question de la défendre
l'environnement est essentielle mais
aujourd'hui malheureusement c'est une
question secondaire c'est à dire que au
lendemain du 13 novembre qu'il faut
d'abord qu'on ait une pensée pour nos
compatriotes nous centrons nos
compatriotes qui sont décédés lors des
attentats dans les rues de paris au
bataclan ou pensée pour les familles des
victimes surtout une pensée pour les nos
compatriotes qui lutte encore entre la
vie et la mort c'était une question
essentielle ensuite sur la question
l'environnement donc demain s'ouvre la
cap 21
bien sûr c'est notre actualité donc est
la vitrine de le fait qu'au 21 c'est à
dire les grands puissants grandes
puissances de ce monde qui se réunissent
pour sauver la planète mais derrière les
beaux discours et finalement les
envolées lyriques pour pour sauver
l'environnement il ya une triste réalité
c'est que depuis 1997 et le protocole le
protocole de kyoto
avec rien n'a été fait rien n'a été fait
c'est à dire qu'on peut faire au niveau
régional si le fn arrive aux
responsables ont été ré ce qu'il fait
sur cette question c'est important c'est
important déjà de situer leur site c'est
un peu le contexte depuis 97 protocole
mais bien sûr bien sûr mais permettez
déjà l'ariège élargi le prisme et
ensuite je viens sur la région s'est
rapidement le temps passe le but de
kyoto c'était de baisser les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre depuis 97
avaient augmenté de 50%
donc au lieu de gérer d'organiser de
grandes conférences qui ne servent à
rien c'est à dire que dans le même temps
de la conférence dont de la cap 21 250
arbres vont être arrachés à paris par
madame hidalgo pour élargir et à grandir
roland garros
dans le même temps vous allez avoir
toute la circulation qui va être bloquée
c'est à dire que nos compatriotes
francilien mais aussi mes compatriotes
de l'yonne qui travaillent en ile de
france vont être pénalisés donc et dans
le même temps la coop 21
j'irai l'organisateur qui s'appelle donc
gl events fait appel à 200 travailleurs
détachés donc qu'ils sont payés
c'est pour vous dire alors après au
niveau régional bien sûr monsieur le
disait et c'est vrai la région enfin les
deux régions les exempter les exécutifs
socialistes donc pas fait as tu es donc
pas fait c'est dans ce domaine là et
nous donc au front national soit pour
une écologie qui ne soit pas une
écologie punitive
sa fille nicole est timide et pour merci
pour parler la coop 21 c'est quand même
is le gouvernement s'est engagé à ce que
le l'ensemble des activités de la coop
21 soit compensé ce qu'ils vont faire le
bilan énergétique on peut le dire aussi
puisqu'on parle des mauvaises choses
faut aussi parler des bonnes un point
sur le sur le aujourd'hui ce que peut
nous apporter une approche
environnementale de notre économie
on se trompe on se trompe en pensant
toujours qu'on va avoir eu des des gens
qui vont penser aux oiseaux etc
quand on parle d'écologie on parle pas
que de ça à l'écologie c'est ce qui va
nous faire vivre demain vous l'avez
mentionné écologie et nous permet de
créer via toutes les énergies
renouvelables et bien d'autres choses
énormément d'emplois et la région a des
moyens concrets pour mettre en place ces
emplois par exemple la formation qui
fait partie des moyens de la région est
un outil extraordinaire pour mettre en
place des outils associant l'énergie
renouvelable associant à l'économie
circulaire il ya des choses à mettre en
place via la formation qui sont
fondamentales et notamment à destination
des pme
parce que pour les pme avoir des
formations sur le sujet c'est quelque
chose auquel n'ont pas nécessairement
accès les grands groupes oui mais une
pme aujourd'hui est ce qu elle sait
qu'elle peut avoir en utilisant des
plastiques recyclés 30% d'économies sur
ses plastiques n'ont pas forcément et
pourtant même si ça reste du plastique
c'est un vrai plus donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on approche c'est ce jeu là pas
uniquement par le biais d'ag puisque
c'est votre question initiale mais par
tous les moyens qui sont à notre
disposition pour le faire et c'est le
rôle de la région
oui la formation c'est trop dur les
régions de citer un extrait important
pour 75% tout de même des moyens qui
proviennent de l'europe et de l'état
sont pour la transition énergétique sont
mis en oeuvre par les collectivités
territoriales et en premier lieu par les
régions ainsi qu'un exemple concernant
d'efficacité énergétique
je la bourgogne et la franche-comté sont
chefs de file et sont les premières à
avoir investi dans des réalisations bbc
la franche comté la première de toutes
les régions françaises et la deuxième la
bourgogne bout parce qu'en fait on a
beaucoup investi dans les bâtiments
basse consommation et donc soit on
souhaite le poursuivre avec un service
public de l'efficacité énergétique qui
reliera tous les territoires pour les
citoyens pour les angles arrive à
l'énergie dans l'appui et conseils
ça c'est un premier point voilà
le deuxième point ces dispositifs
effilogis qui avaient beaucoup marcher
en franche comté
un article du c'est que choisir un
article récent du séquelles choisir
démontre avec les chiffres que avec les
mêmes sommes avec la même quantité
d'argent public en allemagne et en
france on arrive à venir équiper à
isoler 15 fois plus de logements en
allemagne qu'en france tout simplement
parce que là bas on va contrôler le
l'efficacité ici il suffit que les gens
se finir souscrivent à des programmes
qui sont au bénéfice d'entreprises n'est
ce pas et pas au bénéfice de l'économie
d'énergie pour que ce soit validé et
tout ça en gaspillant l'argent public il
y a moyen comme en allemagne de mettre
en place des préfinancements qui
permettent de conserver l'argent public
pour des prochains intérieure plutôt que
de le jeter par la fenêtre n'est ce pas
l'argent public ce ne sont que de les
impôts qui sont détournés de leur
mission de service public vous
réagissiez sur le dispositif et floch
qui est à l'origine de l'isolation de
beaucoup de bâtiments frange des
officiers ce n'est pas aussi efficace
que la reine en sortant le principe le
principe le principe est peut-être bon
son efficacité est tout à fait à
remettre en question je vais simplement
enfin par rapport à ce qui vient d'être
dit depuis quelques minutes
je crois que pour les uns pour les
autres choix que il serait vraiment
dommageable que on surf que certains
surfent sur les événements du 13
novembre et c'est ce que certains
veulent faire aujourd'hui
en déplaçant le lien bas en déplaçant le
débat de la région vers le national
donc au niveau je gagnais n'a pas été
rompue je parle je parle tout seul donc
vous menez ne seront pas s'il vous plaît
donc je vais recentrer sur le débat
régional qu'on peut parler des
régionales le débat régional c'est
quelle place pour l'environnement quelle
place pour le développement responsable
et durable
le principe c'est quelle utilisation
fait-on des données publiques
aujourd'hui ce qui a été mis en place en
bourgogne et en franche comté par
exemple pour hi fi logis un objectif
affiché totalement mais totalement
inopportun et totalement inaccessible de
15 mille logements rénovés par an on est
aujourd'hui au bout de sept ans dix
mille 400 logements août
on a affiché parce que c'est du
populisme quinze mille logements pour
dire qu'on va faire on le savait et tous
les tous les éléments tous les acteurs
économiques du bâtiment disait que
c'était totalement impossible
tout ce que nous prenons ces quinze
mille logements en 2021 en mettant en
place par exemple un passeport qui
permettra au numérique et qui permettra
d'avoir une pré-étude un rapport sur son
habitat mille euros qui seront donnés
donc pour permettre d'avancer dans les
études concrètes
il faut parler du concret de soi faire
la région c'est le la mise en place d'un
d'information pour convier mesdames un
modérateur est un intermédiaire qui
pourrait servir d'intermédiaire entre
les propriétaires qui veulent évoluer
dans l'arrêt brita et les opérateurs
techniques bâtiment btp autres donc tous
là effectivement il y à de vrais leviers
de développement d'une économie liée au
développement du bois responsable a ou
la transition énergétique
mais de grâce recentrons nous sur ce que
va faire la région oui benoît bordât ce
qu'on est les premiers pour les
bâtiments bbc réalisés dont acte mais
c'est 2015 ville peut avoir finalement
et je le sais pas une goutte d'eau est
ce que c'est réellement efficace pour la
lutte pour le réchauffer sans ça en fait
partie c'est la question
on a deux noms à d'autres propositions
puisque c'est de produire localement
l'énergie c'est qu'ils épargnent aux
citoyens sur des projets locaux parce
que les citoyens ils veulent pas que
leur argent parts dans des grands trusts
et ses délires qui veulent voir les
effets de leur épargne âge sur des
projets écologiques environnementaux de
la production d'énergie ça peut être
l'éolien ça peut être la méthanisation
ça peut être la biomasse on a un certain
nombre de projets comme ça qu'on
accompagne
oui parce que vous voulez devenir une
région à énergie positive et puis le
modem aussi bien peu la même chose en
disant nous rendre notre région autonome
mais comment on fait c'est possible on
réduit on réduit les dépenses par les
bâtiments basse consommation et on
produit localement plus le plus
d'énergie parce que là du coup très
concrètement comment on produit plus
d'énergie localement mais comment
changer de centrales nucléaires non
justement on construit des éoliennes
c'est ce qu'on a commencé en bourse et
en france sa dégradation
d'ailleurs je vais citer un exemple
quand j'entends que les éoliennes
dégradent l'environnement il y à
aujourd'hui en france cent mille
kilomètres de lignes à haute tension
expliqué mois ci les lignes haute
tension c'est franchement esthétique et
non j'ai pas dit que c'était mieux
s'inscrire de dire qu'on peut pas y
arriver pour des raisons techniques que
ceci n'est pas beau pièce aussi n'est
pas suffisamment réalisé avec des
finances qu'on aboutit à quoi à ce que
risquent de donner la cap 21 c'est à
dire que 2 de grains va dire ben on est
désolé on peut pas se mettre 2,5
sauf que deux degrés c'est pas une
moyenne parce que j'ai deux degrés c'est
une limite maximum au delà de laquelle
on ne maîtrise plus rien partage donc il
faut rester en souffrance
il faut être incisif sur tout ce qui
vient d'arriver à une région donc à
énergie positive énergie positive
il ya énormément d'énergie renouvelable
a mobilisé alors pour contre le
nucléaire je vais pas revenir sur sur la
question telle que vous l'avez posée de
toute façon on ne peut pas faire sans à
l'heure actuelle donc on va devoir en
termes d'économies de transition le pôle
de compétitivité liés au nucléaire en
bourgogne assure attendu c'est bien sûr
c'est ridicule c'est 15 mai c'est sophie
nicolet
elle avait la parole on lui redonne
nicolet s'est énormément d'emplois
aujourd'hui dans notre région c'est une
énergie certes de transition mais
aujourd'hui et tant que nous n'avons pas
assurer la formation des gens pour
qu'ils aillent vers d'autres énergies
des énergies renouvelables telles que sa
capacité à l'instant benoît bordât sur
la biomasse sur la bioénergie la filière
bois quelque chose d'extrêmement
important pour nous c'est un poisson
localisent en bourgogne
on sait qu'on a une filière bois très
importantes et notamment dans le hainaut
talmant d'un enfant en bourgogne
ces emplois trouveront des transitions
mais pas tout de suite donc on ne peut
pas aujourd'hui supprimer la filière
nucléaire en bourgogne
non nous ne pouvons pas nous n'allons
pas mettre autant personnes au chômage
dans les îles à sion assidon
d'accord je peux faire les régions la
première chose que peuvent faire les
régions la région franche comté
bourgogne en particulier c'est d'abord
de ne pas gaspiller l'argent public
j'ai dit tout ce qui rappelait tout à
l'heure que la france était en faillite
n'est pas l'innovation de l'état aux
différentes collectivités dans les
régions ne cesse de diminuer jusqu'à
terminera mieux aux questions
environnement mais ça n'est pas monsieur
l'environnement il ya des questions de
coûte donc ne peut pas vous ne pouvez
pas me faire le reproche de parler de ça
donc se distribuer de l'argent public
que les régions n'auront pas prétendre
s'avancer en disant qu'on va donner
telle aide
ça ne tient pas debout il faut faire en
sorte mettre en place des procédures qui
soit efficace qui coûtent le moins
possible
quant au nucléaire puisque vous dites
c'est indispensable j'ai regardé avant
de venir ma facture d'électricité 85% de
réussite des filles est d'origine
nucléaire
mais tout l'argent que le gouvernement
est en train de mettre pour continuer
flamanville tout l'argent qu'il est en
train de mettre cela est bien tôt on ne
sait pas ça tout cet argent là c'est de
l'argent qui dépasse investi dans les
énergies renouvelables je suis en forme
et des toitures entre guillemets là
dessus des énergies fossiles est de
l'énergie nucléaire et ça sans que
jamais les citoyens étaient appelés à
donner leur avis alors marché j'aimerais
bien je suis parce que j'ai des arrivées
de cela les policiers me coller décision
sage un consultant finir parce qu'on a
on a commencé sur les énergies
renouvelables et je pense que c'est très
important de d'aller jusqu'au bout
l'éolien parce qu'on avait des débats
mais faut quand même que les gens
sachent là qui nous regardent que de
toute façon l'éolien c'est extrêmement
limité maîtrisé il ya des études qui
sont pris qu'ils sont très solides
on sait très bien que la saône et loire
est une région qui est très peu venté
que la boue la bourgogne franche comté
très peu venté qui a des options dans le
nord de la bourgogne qui en a aussi un
petit peu sur le doubs il y en a très
peu qui veut le projet c'est le plus
gros projet éolien
5 10 ans géographiquement c'est très
limité et je pense qu'on devrait voir
les choses autrement et certains ne
trouve ça très beau les ogm alors je
suis désolé de le dire il ya des gens
qui trouvent ça élégant parce que ça a
un côté flottant dans l'air pourquoi on
en fait pas que les bobos et les
gauchistes c'est vrai que la zone devant
s'arrête à la limite au sud de beaune il
ya du vent le long de la vallée de la
saône et sur la côte jusqu'à ce niveau
là et plus plus bas il y en a plus d'un
seul truc c'est quand même l'exemple de
continuer à investir dans les cluster
éolien puisque c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui absolument et et
du point de vue du point de vue
économique et un développement important
a assuré dans ce domaine l'entreprise
france français all au creusot de
crucell cluster éolien tout ça c'est
important ça fonctionne ça se développe
et ça pourrait se développer beaucoup
plus
la filière est incomplète on n'a pas les
générateurs par exemple mais déjà la
fabrication des mâts et ça permet de
reconvertir les gens dont la spécialité
de travailler dans la métallurgie et qui
actuellement se retrouvent au chômage du
côté d'areva
je voulais arrêter le développement de
l'éolien en bourgogne franche comté tout
à fait exactement déjà pour répondre à
monsieur sur le nucléaire bon on sait
aujourd'hui est totalement irresponsable
voire stupide de se passer du nucléaire
ni responsable ni si la pile qui la
seule énergie les autres et pas cher
donc qui connecte restée pas chers
concitoyens cher c'est extraordinaire
a demandé à ce qu'on ne vous interrompre
à laisser parler monsieur accepté
l'arrêt que je vous proposais tout à
l'heure donc j'interviendrai c'est nous
qui fixons les règles de la suite sur
sur le développement de l'éolien on
voyait le dogmatisme des verts est
finalement et donc du ps puisque se bat
pas contre des moulins à vent non les
construit oui enfin voilà exactement et
qu'elle est le résultat ça dégrade
considérablement l'environnement jeu
l'environnement visuel vous vivez pas
côté d'une éolienne monsieur mais vous
heureusement n'ont heureusement non mais
je connais le notamment énormément de
communes notamment dans le chablisien
vous voyez donc des paysages magnifiques
qui sont souillés par le développement
des éoliennes et je pense notamment dans
quelle est la commune de prix donc où
les habitants se mobilisent avec
acharnement
donc on joue contre l'encerclement d'un
parc éolien
je veux dire même pour le tourisme c'est
une entrave
quelle est l'alternative du coup
développer les énergies renouvelables
vous avez déjà sans bien sûr pionnier en
fait partie mais ensuite il faut voir
l'éolien offshore et aucun problème mais
quand vous avez du mal
oui mais voilà ne vous dit hostile à la
ligne au talent unique d'éolien qu'on
propose à ceux ci le mix énergétique
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est la
méthanisation c'est de la biomasse c'est
du solaire on n'est pas sur un modèle
unique on sait que l'éolien a atteint un
stade et qu'on ne peut pas faire plus de
20% de la production d'électricité en
éolien puisqu'après se dit qu'il faut
déjà penser à l'environnement pour nous
constitue hélas on y pense tous les
jours nos concitoyens leur cadre de vie
c'est ça une écologie humaniste et
nounkeu logique dogmatique donc que vous
prenez et bien relever des parts à pau
par rapport au développement du
responsable par rapport à l'énergie en
particulier faut pas oublier un élément
qui est la précarité énergétique
on a aujourd'hui plus de 15% des foyers
en bourgogne franche comté qui sont
touchés par la précarité énergétique
donc les régions la fronde et joue a
comme objectif justement et nous avons
comme objectif de travailler en
coopération avec les bailleurs sociaux
avec les bailleurs propriétaires avec
les locataires humaines pour qu'il
retrouve du pouvoir d'achat à travers
une baisse de leur facture énergétique
quand on parle de précarité énergétique
on parle de coupe de l'énergie on le
sait très bien c'est pour ça que la
réponse ne peut pas être absolu comme
certains veulent bien entendre on a
besoin du nucléaire il faut mettre la
sécurité en priorité et si il dit à
sécurité il faut peut-être sûr mais
certains réacteurs
mais certainement pas par principe
arrêté de lui faire ça serait une
aberration à la fois économique et
énergétique
en revanche mais non en revanche il faut
il faut tendre vers un transfert de
l'énergie nucléaire vers d'autres ce
type d'énergie mais avec des objectifs
qui soient réalistes et non pas comme
ceux qui ont été affichées par dans le
schéma de cohérence énergétiques
écologiques pardon ou le srcae qui a été
proposé par là la région de
franche-comté qui est totalement
inatteignable inatteignable quand on
veut consacrer du bois il doit consacrer
une telle capacité en bois énergie on va
aller mais j'espère que vous aurez de
conscience ce qu'avait proposé ça on va
à les anéantir une des ressources les
plus compliqués à construire qu'est la
forêt à travers les objectifs de bois
énergie qu'on a inscrit dans le rcl
fokam le savoir et on va faire des
centaines de poids lourds de grumier qui
vont prendre les routes pour aller
chercher du bois énergie pour faire quoi
pour détruire la forêt parce qu'il faut
50 60 entre la reconstituer pour ne rien
apporter au bout donc il faut avoir des
politiques qu'ils soient territorialisée
que ne pas avoir des grands schémas ce
qu'on se bat des grands schémas qui
finalement ne colle pas du tout aux
spécificités des terrains des noms
bourdin vous allez détruire la forêt on
va pas détruire la forêt ya d'autres
dispositifs pour certains adultes
c'était très compliqué de monter des
projets on l'a vu avec quercia notamment
dans la nièce un projet finalement qui a
capoté alors qu'il y ait aussi un projet
réussi quand on associe tous les acteurs
du territoire donc aujourd'hui il faut
il faut il faut il faut laisser pas les
consommateurs au projet mais ne pouvait
pas la parole s'il vous plaît je ne vous
ai pas couper la parole
donc dans ce modèle là il faut associer
des acteurs de territoire et puis dans
le modèle bois il ya les déchets du bois
il ya des coupes de bois il ya les
taillis boya les tailles de haies ya
aussi des entreprises aujourd'hui avec
de l'investissement des privée et
l'investissement public aujourd'hui se
développe sur de la biomasse et pour les
réseaux de chaleur la russie a capoté
parce que grâce à l'intervention des
associations locales et d'europe
écologie les verts y compris à l'échelon
européen et donc c'est compliqué l'agent
extraction été fait de façon évidente
que ce projet qui consistait à faire des
granulés de bois pour les envoyer vers
dire l'économie de la production
électrique en belgique et dont le
principal sponsor était un transporteur
luxembourgeois ça ne tenait évidemment
pas la route ni du point de vue
économique c'est donc bon je veux juste
revenir à vous parce que vous proposer
un service public je crois de
l'efficacité énergétique ça veut dire
quoi c'est encore une commission
théodule du ps technique et ciani si
vous placez sur la somme encore là pour
organiser le débat peut-être donc je
suis citoyen c'est moi qui paye les
avons pas besoin at il soufflé cette
idée d'associer puisque justement c'est
des dossiers techniques ces déchets qui
sont compliquées donc c'est à la fois de
mettre autour de la table les
entreprises les citoyens qui veulent
changer leur habitation faire des
modifications faire des travaux de
rénovation énergétique et c'est de les
accompagner dans le montage de ces
dossiers de les accompagner dans les
aides qu'ils pourront obtenir auprès du
conseil régional qu'on permettra d'avoir
un vrai service optimale et d'orienter
tout le monde dans la bonne direction
la france est en faillite ces êtres dont
vous parlez disparaîtront très bientôt
et heureusement qu'on nous les trois
propositions très concrètes par rapport
à cela
c'est donc la mise en place d'un
passeport énergétique donc 1000 euros
qui sont donc sous la forme d'une carte
numérique qui permettront aux
propriétaires de pouvoir faire un
une estimation de leur consommation
énergétique de pour avoir un rapport
d'étude thermique sur leurs habitations
et ensuite les propositions d'évolution
et habite à deux ans de la région
offrirait 1000 euros pour ses
actionnaires ce pont dubuc avec un
engagement bien sûr de passer par des
sociétés habilitées à gré pour faire
c'était sébastien énergétique
deuxièmement cela développement comme je
disais tout à l'heure
l'invité de coordinateur dans le dos les
rénovations qui servirait
d'intermédiaire entre des propriétaires
et puis les acteurs économiques
et puis c'est le plan vivre mieux avec
cet objectif de 15 mille logements en
2021 rénové avec la mise en place d'une
structure bancaire qui porterait les
coûts des travaux financés par la bei
des plateformes transition énergétique
de manière à ce qu effectivement des
situations où le nombre de gens qui
puissent isoler leur logement qui était
aujourd'hui très insuffisant c'est exact
pour que ces gens puissent s'y retrouver
il faut coordonner tout ça il faut
coordonner les artisans aussi pour que
les artistes puissent intervenir sans
être uniquement des sous traitants
grosse boîte
il faut faire ça à l'échelle à peu près
de 10000 habitants quelque chose comme
ça ça doit passer donc aussi par les
opci et la région un représentant à
jouer l'agglomération établissements
publics communes et donc la région un
rôle essentiel à jouer là dedans et ça
ça doit multiplier par au moins par dix
la possibilité de rénovation énergétique
t on aller on a beaucoup parlé et n'a
énergie et on va parler un peu de
l'agriculture les suffrages des surfaces
bio ne représente finalement que six
pour cent à des terres agricoles en
bourgogne franche comté entre 2014 et
2015 + 25 % comme en bourgogne un nombre
de conversions multiplié par deux et
demi en franche comté
c'est un vrai élan qu'il faut continuer
à soutenir ou est ce qu'il faut avant
tout aider les exploitations existantes
une vraie inquiétude de la part des
agriculteurs et dessus sophie les
goulags
je pense qu'il faut travailler sur le
bio mais pas que sur le bio il faut
aussi travailler sur l'agriculture
raisonnée puisque les agriculteurs sont
aussi fiers les viticulteurs alors les
des éleveurs sont aussi fiers de leur
terroir et de leurs régions que nous
sommes est
et ils n'ont pas envie non plus de faire
n'importe quoi donc il faut qu'on les
aide et qu'on les accompagne nous là
dessus on propose quelque chose qui est
très concret mais qui est la création
d'une
une académie régionale agricole qui
permettraient non qui permettrait de
faire en sorte que les gens puissent les
agriculteurs puissent se rencontrer
puissent échanger puisse continuer
d'apprendre en toujours en formation
continue il ya énormément de changements
qui vont venir et c'est se tromper de
parler d'aujourd'hui de l'environnement
sans parler à du big data sans parler de
toutes ces choses parce que demain nous
allons beaucoup mieux connaître nos
territoires nous allons vers des données
qui vont nous permettre d'adapter nous
saurons dire quels sont les taux de
pesticides au quotidien qui sont qui
sont injectés et nous serons les mesures
est bien mieux et à prendre demain à aux
agriculteurs aux éleveurs et à utiliser
tous ses outils et mettre en commun les
différentes connaissances qu'ont et
j'agis culture ont besoin de la région
pour ça il lui dit on pas déjà sûr on va
continuer d aider il faut qu'on les aide
jetez un oeil à un moment donné où on
peut distribuer des aides mais ça ne
suffira pas et comme vous le mentionnez
nous n'avons pas les moyens de le faire
si on a reconnu jean la gale travailler
intelligemment
non parce que comme vous lisiez ils le
font déjà il ya des syndicats qui le
font et l'idée c'est de continuer de
mettre en relation ces gens mais aussi
avec d'autres acteurs par exemple des
chercheurs on a on a aussi le pôle
vitagora qui qui se développe et qui va
développer très fortement à dijon avec
la cité de la gastronomie mettons tous
ces acteurs là ensemble parce que ce
sont ces acteurs-là qui connaissent le
mieux leur domaine et qui vont pouvoir
faire avancer nos connaissances genre à
la croix je n'entend parler que d'une
usine à gaz de structures
intercommunales ou régionales ou
impliquant six de suite c'est à dire
deux choses qui fonctionnent qu'avec des
règlements un peu de bon sens jusqu'à 25
ans parce que je suis fils de paysan est
fier d'être fils de paysan j'ai depuis
des vaches j'ai fait tout ce que font
les petits paysans mon père n'a jamais
reçu la moindre aide
il aurait été honteux de demander la
moindre aide à qui que ce soit il s'est
débrouillé tout seul il a travaillé
beaucoup et il a fini par affectivement
par une exploitation qui machin qui
était rentable
non monsieur laissez-moi times affirmé
mais dès qu'ils sont corinne aucune
monsieur aucune jamais et dans les six
mois qui suivent sa mort tous les
déchets qui devrait générer était
recyclé pas et il n'y avait pas de
choses qui traînait comme des pesticides
comme et qui polluent notre territoire
quel est le coût des pesticides pour
revenir un tout petit peu en arrière
qu'elle ne coûte de tchernobyl en
particulier sur les eaux du jura sur les
plateaux du jura qu'elles ne coûtent de
fukushima le prochain accident nucléaire
qui se produiraient vraisemblement en
france compte tenu du nombre de visites
à l'unité de production électrique chez
nous ce sera on a de bonnes chances que
ce soit chez nous quel en sera le coût
tu donc si vous voulez prétendre entre
guillemets ne pas parler des nains ne
peut parler d'économie au prétexte qu'on
parle d'agriculture ce que moi je
propose je te propose l'alliance est
tout simplement qu'on en revienne à des
choses simples comme qu'on laisse qu'on
libère l'énergie plutôt que de la
contrainte en permanence par des
réglementations qui ne profite qu'à
quelques reins kadri lobby et ça les
citoyens peuvent l'entendre puisque en
permanence ils sont en train de
protester ils n'accordent plus aucune
confiance aux politiciens qui les avait
pas de mabanda jeu de monsieur monsieur
excusez moi je peux monsieur n'aime pas
les usines à gaz et là vous faites un
tunnel à gaza sert strictement à rien la
première question fait sur les
agriculteurs vont reprendre fin du tour
de table alors évidemment qu'il faut les
soutenir et j'ai redit que nous nous
agriculteurs ce coureur des mendiants
gens pas des mendiants les pays si vous
êtes sur la croix il on peut laisser
s'exprimer les autres candidats monsieur
les contre-vérités ils sont difficiles
de l'elysée
c'est compliqué de ces crimes et je
voulais dire où il est important de
soutien aux agriculteurs et notamment la
région le peu en valorisant défendant le
patriotisme alimentaire faisant en sorte
donc que dans nos lycées on mange on
consomme français lassés paraît une
évidence apparaît logique pourtant ce
n'est pas le cas donc si sophie montel
était du président de la région dans
tous les lycées et établissements
publics de la région ce sera notamment
de la viande mais on a les moyens de le
faire parce qu'il ya des dizaines de
milliers de repas qui sont servis chaque
jour on est capable de le faire bien sûr
quoi on a les capacités c'est uniquement
une choix politiques
voilà malheureusement nous évite
régionales actuelles favorisent de la
viande d'allemagne favorise des produits
même hors union européenne
alors qu'on peut justement valoriser et
défendre nos productions nos producteurs
avec en soutenant leur leur travail ça
existe déjà notamment les circuits
courts via la plateforme locale
notamment alan tous les éléments de
bilan de ce qui a été fait par la
bourgogne par la franchir qui sera même
proposé de nouveau mais nous qu'est ce
qu'on propose le voit déjà je voudrais
dire que on est fiers de nos
agriculteurs on est fiers de nos
agricultures parce qu'on parle de
plusieurs agriculture il faut pas
opposer les modèles il faut soutenir
l'agriculture biologique
il faut soutenir le développement d'une
agriculture de l'agroécologie il faut
pas opposer les modèles maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on propose
bientôt sa mère tout le monde mais il
faut soutenir tous les maux neige d'un
registre avec nous on soutient
l'agroécologie on soutient les
agriculteurs dans des démarches plus
vertueuse dans des partenariats gagnant
gagnant
mais je vais je vais laisser martins
hélas en relais
quand même qu'on parle ici aux gens de
propositions parce qu'on peut débattre
entre nous pendant des heures et des
heures mais moi je vais parler des
propositions comporte donc céder ni
vraiment le soutien aux filières courtes
le soutien aux circuits courts mais
c'est aussi la problématique de
l'installation de jeunes agriculteurs
qui ont de plus en plus de mal à
s'installer et donc là nous on veut
mettre en place une politique foncière
pour à la fois les aider s'installer et
les aider à s'installer sur des
exploitations structure et parce qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent dégâts économiques
sur sur les exploitations qui soit sûre
d exploitation rentable
on veut aussi mais ça veut dire non une
aide alors que concrètement en fait
c'est une aide financière non la cc avec
les chiens place une politique foncière
en fait une structuration foncière ou
via des intermédiaires via les
organisations professionnelles agricoles
ou la safer on met en place une réserve
foncière où on aide
l'installation est une structure
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
qui ont de plus en plus de difficultés
je dire voilà il ya d'autres d'autres
sujets c'est aussi l'agriculture de
qualité qui est très inspiré en franche
comté et avec un système de coopérative
et un système de solidarité
il ya des fruits terre et ça c'est des
modèles qu'on souhaite développer ses
accompagner les projets collectifs des
exploitants agricoles
voilà monsieur l'auto se retrouver tout
ça n'est pas très clair mais on n'a
évidemment pas le temps dans la durée de
cette émission danse compliquées sur la
pac et solidaire à les initier une
manière d tat d'été c'est d'être à la
fois général est clair en disant que par
exemple la fédération nationale
d'agriculture biologique qui est un
établissement public d'état a dit que la
filière bio générait 2,4 unités de
travail annuel contre 1,5 pour le
conventionnel donc voilà un lien entre
la nécessité de développer l'agriculture
biologique et la nécessité de créer des
emplois les écologistes critiquent
notamment sur les bilans des exécutifs
sortants notamment orange comptait par
rapport à la leur au bilan en matière
d'agriculture bio à manger aux exécutifs
sortants de croiser apparteniez
d'ailleurs absolument mais c'est pas
parce qu'une et appartient qu on arrive
à obtenir tout ce qu'on veut mais il
faut y appartenir le plus possible pour
en obtenir davantage
je connais évidemment mieux le sujet de
la bourgogne mais c'est vrai qu'en
franche-comté il s'est pas fait grand
chose c'est en effet un peu plus en
bourgogne on peut pas nier notamment que
la belette été la première région à se
déclarer sans ogm par exemple mais mais
les mots et les choses c'est des fois 2
à ces différents par exemple si on prend
le soutien des mandants part en tête
après je ne sais pas des sites natura
ça joue sur la transition de
l'agriculture lorsque la région
bourgogne décident d'abaisser ces aides
de 2 d'un tiers sur les sur la
conversion d agriculture les projets de
conversions d'agriculteurs installés en
zone natura 2000 ça fragilise énormément
le développement des pratiques agricoles
respectueuses de l'environnement
sur ces secteurs est et surtout le
l'environnement de ces secteurs
donc pour dit des choses mais en même
temps on fait le contraire
donc voilà c'est bien d'avancer mais il
faudrait aussi que les les faits par
exemple les confédérés son lorsque la
moitié ne finance que la moitié de du
besoin de développement de 2 de surfaces
agricoles biologiques 6000 hectares pour
treize mille hectares par exemple pour
la région bourgogne
donc il faut que la que la région
apporte le complément patrick genre j'ai
eu l'impression depuis le début de la
campagne que françois sauvadet opposer
systématiquement développement de
l'agriculture et écologie dans ce que ce
que françois des défend est ce que moi
je revendique également c'est d'arrêter
cette écologie punitive je l'expliquais
pour l'agriculture la sylviculture ce
que je faisais partie monsieur vous
pouvez rigoler je faisais partie de la
commission régime d'installation et je
peux vous dire je peux vous dire sans
crainte nous disent ici je peux vous
dire je peux vous dire je peux vous dire
que par la mise en place de je dirais
d'éléments très coercitif très fléchant
eh bien on annule il développe ment
nicole nous on est pour un développement
agricole multiples et variées et
plurielle donc je ne peux pas faire que
du bio travailler aussi sur
l'agriculture non intervention bien
entendu mais c'est une utopie de faire
que du bio je ne suis pas persuadé
qu'ils ne faisait d'art et essai
nucléaire c'est pas forcément ce n'est
pas forcément de vouloir tout faire dans
un seul panier qui fera avancer des
choses donc il faut avoir une approche
multiple il faut arrêter aussi comme
certains le font les verts en
particulier de stigmatiser et de mettre
en exergue dû dire que l auteur sondés
des sculptures de nature ne respectes
civile
si on me dit s'il y a bien s'il ya bien
prenez plaisir à nous le faire c'est les
personnes s'il ya bien des personnes qui
dépendent justement de la défense de
leur patrimoine de leur eu du travail
c'est bien des sculpteurs qui font tous
orientés des exemples malheureux mais la
très grande majorité développent une
inculture 7
il faut donc travailler très rapidement
sur très vite très vite sur des filières
de proximité alors courte bio place et
de proximité qui et réduiront donc la
partie car donne pour les déplacements
des produits alimentaires travailler en
coopération avec le département qui ont
la gestion des collèges pour faire en
sorte que entre les lycées et les
collèges ses 60 millions de repas que
nous avons servir en bourgogne trois
côtés par en faire en sorte que ces
repas puisse être traitée à travers le
travail des filières
à travers donc le rapprochement des
acteurs locaux avec les gestionnaires de
ces établissements qu'on ait des
circuits courts de production et
d'alimentation et travaillé aussi pour
que l'agriculture puisse ne pas je
rejoins les agriculteurs ne demande pas
de subventions ils souhaitent simplement
vivre de leurs produits de la
reproduction et donc il faut donc que
nous arrivions à travailler sur une
diversification des revenus par exemple
avec la méthanisation ou le
photovoltaïque pourquoi pas et
travailler avec des aides de la région
envers acceptable mais benoît bordât
pourquoi les lycées unique entité s'il
vous plaît je parle
et pourquoi les cantines des lycées ne
sont pas assez approvisionné en produits
locaux aujourd'hui on a effectivement ça
paraît simple sa part à une idée voilà
ça pour ça c'est pas forcément le cas
chaque chaque s'il vous plaît chaque
cuisine de lycée fonctionne différemment
après on va rentrer dans un débat
technique mais il ya des fois des
cuisines qui fonctionne en liaison
froide d'autres en liaison chaude ça n'a
pas le même impact sur ce qu'on va
servir dans l'assiette et pour les ans
quand on fonctionne dès fois en liaison
froide avec une cuisine centrale qui
cuisinent pour d'autres il des fois pas
de petit légumes riz local et ne peuvent
pas ça provient en produits bruts logo
il faut acheter les quatrièmes galles
qui défaut est fait par des industriels
donc nous notre rôle aussi pour
accélérer la fourniture de produits
locaux dans les cantines des lycées
ça va être de les aider à financer des
micro légumerie au sein des lycées pour
mettre des produits locaux dans dans le
dans les plats délicieux et qu'elle est
plus globalement pour pour favoriser
cette alimentation de proximité j'allais
dire est ce que la halle
le conseil régional a aussi son mot à
dire et sa fonction à jouer on a tous
notre rôle je n'ai pas compris fin pour
pour développer justement balo le les
circuits courts l'alimentation de
proximité ce qu'ont à bercy
l'alimentation de proximité est ce que
la région participe via les financements
européens au développement des filières
courtes au développement des ateliers de
transformation chez les chez les
producteurs
par exemple pour la rénovation ou
l'amélioration d'une miellerie ou pour
quelqu'un qui fait kiffer ses concerts
de charcuterie fermière on les
accompagne pour cette transformation on
les accompagne aussi pour des projets
par exemple des projets de deux drives
fermiers des projets de magasins locaux
ça c'est tout un accompagnement qu'on
fait déjà et poursuivra dans le prochain
mandat
juste un mot il ya des choses aussi très
simple qu'on pourrait mettre en place et
il existe un logiciel qui s'appelle la
grille locale qui permet de mettre en
relation s'était développé dans la drôme
mais c'est déjà en place dans le
territoire de belfort
ça permet de mettre en relation les
producteurs et les besoins des
collectivités
ce qui fait que ça nous permettrait si
la cie la région investissez dans ce
logiciel tout simplement de donner et de
faciliter les choses pas partout mais ça
ne suffit pas de faire la liste on n'a
pas le temps la liste de tout ce qui est
possible l'aide aux investissements
transformation à la ferme
les deux circuits courts les politiques
des leaders et dans les lycées à ce
sujet là la charte de qualité de la
restauration scolaire durable 2015 2019
le bien dans mon assiette etc etc
on n'a pas le temps de faire ça tout ça
c'est tout simplement munication a
simplement s'occuper de ce qu est un mec
est on peut pas faire taire deux grandes
questions qui n'existe qu'une fois tous
les six ans dans les dents lorsqu'ils
lorsqu'il élections parce que l'égalité
n'est pas respecté le joueur donc qu' il
ne s'agit pas uniquement de de parler
des choses et de faire un petit un petit
peu de ça on a pas de différence
fondamentale sur le fond de ce point de
vue là à fait d'accord simplement il
faut agir et il faut ce qu'on fait à 1
le faire à 10 on sent des clients d'ubs
demandé
les rapprochements de l'entre-deux-tours
ex en train de s'esquisser ce cas vous
disent qu'ils ont de rapprochement entre
deux tours c'est une question du fait
ces jours-ci on reconnaît ce qui est
terrible c'est que la leaf 1 les gones
les français qui nous regardent à mon
avis ne n'y comprennent rien et on
comprend pourquoi il s'éloigne
finalement des problématiques
environnementales et de la défense donc
de le cadre de vie parce que c'est de la
communication parce que vous égrainé des
propositions qui ne veulent rien dire
les lancements je comprends que
bourgogne au match se gagne 1 degrés de
hausse de température depuis 80 il va le
voir du concret et de chez vous le
concret c'est uniquement la rentabilité
alors oui chez vous a volé au national
encore une fois si vous arrivez aux
affaires monsieur odoul qu'est ce qui va
changer en matière environnementale soit
et conclure des déjà faut être concret
il faut pas mentir aux français
il faut leur dire que au niveau de la
région on aura des pouvoirs illimités
on n'a pas pouvoir rendre la donzelle
franche-comté verte en attaque man 2
doit tout de suite j'ai dernière région
des ath de france oui non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est communiste et au niveau
déjà de l'état que ça pourra se passer
donc en 10 75 fois en 2010 celle ci en
2017 s'il y avait vraiment une
alternative
et pour le coup une alternative
patriotes ensuite sur ce que je jouais
dire par rapport à ce que vous avez dit
c'était une incapacité dramatique que
vous que vous nous dites c'est à dire on
peut faire que 80% de patriotisme
alimentaire on peut monsieur qui dit où
il n'ya pas de légumes riz à côté durant
six ans on pouvait passer devant
athenes c'est à dire que vous préférez
faire appelle donc à des producteurs
étrangers et donc à des viandes et
légumes qui viennent qui ne font pas
qu'ils viennent pas de france pour
nourrir nos lycéens ces deux races est
dramatique c'est le message que vous
envoyez donc à nos agriculteurs de leur
dire que leur travail ne sert à rien et
ne pourra pas être valorisés dans mon
discours je préfère pas vous répondre je
pensais pas bon si c'est votre
conception des dépenses racing c'est ce
que vous vous en dire c'est qu'on dira
les gens savent ce qu on fait ce qu'on a
fait pour les lycées ce qu'on va
continuer à faire pour les lycées ils le
savent déjà mais ça déjà on a mis en
place locale en bourgogne qu'un
dispositif qui met les fournisseurs et
les acheteurs des lycées en concordance
pour les inciter à acheter des produits
locaux
voilà et après il ya des problématiques
de prison des prix à respecter et puis
on produira c'est ce que les produits
dans l'agro écologie qui vous dans
l'agriculture biologique qu'on arrivera
à rendre accessible à tout le monde ce
qui fait personne ne dise que la région
a totalement par la main mais
globalement la le poids des décisions à
travers le budget qu'elle alloue ont
laissé personne ne l'évoqué
s'il ya bien un levier sur lequel la
région peut jouer pour orienter les
politiques applicables dans les lycées
par exemple mais dans les autres
transports et autres c'est bien par le
budget qu'elle délègue au lycée donc
s'il ya une orientation politique
volonté pour les régions il peut y avoir
transformation sur le terrain la réponse
est toute simple c'est quelles
orientations budgétaires donne t'on à
travers les attributions que la région
confiera ac dc j'ai un poids tout ça
c'est le ce qu'on n'a pas dit encore
mais qui est très important et je pense
que si on a l'occasion d'être écoutés
c'est vraiment le dire le première chose
à faire pour améliorer notre
environnement c'est limiter le
gaspillage et ça on a tous les moyens de
le mettre en place et la région en a les
moyens
mais c'est quelque chose qui ne coûte
rien mais de s'assurer qu'on n'utilise
ce que c'est donc moi j'ai de l'énergie
des déchets je parle de tous les
filières on a besoin de mettre en place
des filières de retraitement des déchets
on a besoin de s'assurer que les
entreprises peuvent utiliser ce qui a
été retraités
on a besoin de s'assurer que dans les
cantines il n'y ait pas de gaspillage on
a besoin de s'assurer à tous ces niveaux
là on a besoin de s'assurer qu'on n'a
pas de l'espêche c'est le premier levier
que nous avons tous et je pense à tout
ce qu'on appelle l'économie
circulaire est ce que comment la
développer comment vous la mettez en
place parce que c'est peut-être facile à
dire mais c'est plus compliqué à
réaliser non si on regarde le bilan de
la mise en oeuvre de ces politiques
c'est tout simplement que les
agriculteurs n'ont jamais été aussi
endetté qu'il ya de plus en plus de
difficultés pour l'installation des
jeunes pousses pas que les aliments qui
sont distribués sont de plus en plus
polluée quant aux résidus de pesticides
dans les eaux mais mieux la france vient
de publier des statistiques il n'y a
jamais eu autant la france étant le
premier producteur de ses produits la
vieille dame a bien signé avec ma
question j'avais surtout écoutez
monsieur je termine parce que c'est moi
qui fais la campagne ce n'est pas vous
qui faites l'air mais c'est moi qui fais
cette émission et être maître simplement
dire monsieur c'est que la police la
poursuite de cette politique de
distribution d'argent public au lobby
productiviste avec des belles paroles
environnementale en ne respectant aucun
des termes de la charte
consciente constitutionnel environnement
abouti à une situation qui est ingérable
en tous les cas les consommateurs mais
si free lance ce bordel et j'emploie le
terme à dessein n'est ce pas eux ne sont
pas associés à la définition de la
politique agricole commune lors qu'ils
sont les premiers intéressés ils sont
demandeurs de produits de sailpoint des
enjeux régionaux l'économie si je meurs
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas les camps nous
avons rendez vous une question à sophie
nicolet s'il vous plaît sur l'économie
circulaire à ce que voulait la
développer comment on fait concrètement
on est la quatrième région productrice
métal aujourd'hui en france pour quelle
franche comté je pense qu'il ya des
choses à faire sur leur traitement des
métaux on sait qu'il ya des choses sur
l'aluminium que l'aluminium est très
largement réutilisables une fois qu'ils
le recycler en revanche il n'est pas il
ne l'est pas nécessairement en termes de
dali mentalités donc là il ya des choses
à faire il ya peu une filière qui
existait des choses à travailler
je pense qu'il faut qu'on aille sur tous
ces domaines là pour arriver à
travailler il ya un autre point qui est
très important qui alors certes un peu
productiviste mais l'impression 3d dont
on a beaucoup parlé
c'est quelque chose qui va être
extrêmement important dans toute la
logique de ce qu'on appelle
remanufacturing c'est à dire le fait de
faire vivre les produits le plus
longtemps possible
pourquoi parce qu'on va pouvoir produire
nous mêmes dans des centres qui doivent
être accessibles à tous les francs
comtois tous les bourguignons descente
qui permettront de réparer des pièces
qui sont abîmés et du coup de faire
vivre plus longtemps des produits et de
pas de faire en sorte que
évidemment les gens n'aient pas besoin
de renouveler complètement leurs
produits devraient acheter de re
consommer et là c'est à la région
d'aider ce type de je pense que c'est à
la région d'aider à la mise en place de
ce type de centre surtout que c'est
extrêmement important que la vision de
la région qu'elle a que la région impose
une vision et qu'elles soient pas
simplement gestionnaire qu'elle soit
carré au delà et c'est typiquement des
politiques d'investissement on doit
pousser à l'île madame messieurs le
l'émission arrive à son terme on va vous
demander à chacun de conclusion de 45
secondes vous adresser aux électeurs de
bourgogne franche comté et on a tiré au
sort lors de cette conclusion on
commence avec eric on compense avec et
françois lotteau qui a été le premier
tirage au sort très bien et qui n'a pas
vous savez qu'il ya urgence
vous avez compris qu'il ne faut plus
dépendre du pétrole du charbon du gaz et
de l'uranium le monde qui en dépend
s'écroule
il faut changer vous voulez vivre en
bonne santé vous voulez un air
respirable une eau claire une
alimentation saine produites localement
un logement isolé des énergies
renouvelables des transports propres
facile et pas cher des entreprises qui
se convertissent où naissent dans des
filières d'avenir et créent des emplois
nombreux
la région détient qu'une grande partie
du pouvoir d'agir sur tout cela il faut
des élus écologistes à la région pour
porter ce combat pour porter votre voix
pour agir concrètement une manière
cohérente
merci ils seront les seuls à le faire il
faut qu'ils soient nombreux chaque
bulletin pour europe ecologie les verts
contrat le 6 décembre pour passer votre
match car si françois lotteau patrick
genre c'est à vous et je crois que dans
le cadre du développement durable et
responsable françois sauvadet apporte
des solutions qui sont concrètes qui
sont réalistes qui seront évalués comme
chacune des politiques mises en place
puisqu'il ya un engagement d'évaluation
annuelle des politiques mises en place
nous souhaitons faire du développement
durable et responsable un vrai levier de
croissance qui préserve la capacité
d'investissement et de développement
économiques actuelles parce que rien ne
se fera sans la valeur ajoutée apportée
par l'économie y compris dans le domaine
du développement responsable et durable
on ne pourra pas financer des politiques
de soutien à la biodiversité par exemple
si nous n'avons pas d'avs à la revue
d'économie donc avoir des solutions
concrètes réalistes et surtout dernier
mot il faut bien entendu dans le cadre
général des élections une mobilisation
de tous les électrices et de tous les
électeurs
pour que le vote se réalisent et que le
vote soit sur des fonctions régionales
et non pas sur des vocations
ne nous trompons pas d'élection remercie
patrick jean sophie me connaissent et à
bukuru 45 sans merci avec christophe rue
de la baume et on a fait de la de
l'environnement et de l'indépendance
énergétique en effet un point majeur
notre programme ni par angélisme ni par
dogmatisme
on a décidé de faire ça et de leur encre
et de le faire en faire une clé de voûte
parce qu'il s'agit d'un réservoir
d'emplois très important pour notre
région
parce que il s'agit d'un facteur de
croissance pour nos entreprises et d'un
facteur d'amélioration du pouvoir
d'achat des citoyens et parce que si on
veut que nos enfants puissent vivre dans
le monde dans lequel nous avons vécu
aussi bien que nous pouvons vivre
aujourd'hui voire mieux
alors voilà dimanche prochain nous
comptons sur vous vraiment on a besoin
on a besoin d'un analyste indépendant de
citoyenne à ces jeunes par ailleurs donc
si c'est maintenant qu'on peut faire
changer les choses il faut y aller
julien odoul pour le front national
la transition énergétique donc est une
urgence c'est une urgence en terme
d'emploi l'urgence en termes de santé
une urgence thème d'indépendance
nationale et de protection de notre
environnement
donc au sein de notre région il faut
mettre une politique industrielle
écologique ambitieuse et investir
massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables
l'ump comme le ps et les verts leurs
alliés n'ont pas les outils parce qu'ils
sont tenus par l'union européenne
l'austérité est donc ce carcan du libre
échange avec sophie montel nous avons
les outils
c'est à dire le protectionnisme
intelligent le colbertisme le
patriotisme alimentaire
la défense de notre patrimoine et de
notre environnement de nos forêts donc
le 6 et 13 décembre
il faut voter massivement pour sophie
montel la seule candidate écologiste et
patriote merci julien odoul benoît
bordât pour la liste de marie j'irai
j'ai envie de vous dire vous l'avez vu
on avait nous à certains de nos
propositions puisque total ce sont 110
propositions pour la bourgogne et la
franche-comté donc déjà j'invite tous
les bourguignons et tous les francs
comtois aller sur notre région d'avant
ce point fr consulter ses 110
propositions je crois qu'on est les
seuls à avoir détaillé autant ces
propositions là puisque nous on propose
une grande région qui soit plus
vertueuses qui soit vecteur de
solidarité de justice sociale de soutien
à l'emploi et à la formation de
préservation et la trique d'attractivité
de notre cadre de vie et bien sûr de
faire de la transition écologique la
biodiversité un des fers de lance de
notre région qui déjà repris
surat sortant ou deux points par le
bilan voilà et c'est comme dirait
marie-guite dufay la politique par la
preuve
gérard lacroix votre conclusion s'il
vous plaît merci j'ai une pensée pour
les victimes des attentats
il ya effectivement une urgence
sécuritaire par contre aucune urgence
électorale pour conforter la fusion
forcée des régions sans que les citoyens
aient été consultés
il s'agit d'un véritable attentat contre
la démocratie locale
la france est en faillite tant que les
citoyens consommateurs qui payent leurs
impôts ne seront pas associés
concrètement à la définition des
politiques régionales rien n'avancera
dans ce pays
merci à tous les six merci et rien ni
prochain débat demain dimanche donc à
11h sur le développement économique et
la formation professionnelle avec six
autres candidats et puis le grand débat
des têtes de listes régionales c'est
mercredi soir à 22h30 avec madame du
fait monsieur sauvadet madame montel
madame prud'hommes madame vermorel et
monsieur grudler j'ai oublié personne
les six principales têtes de liste grand
débat donc à 22h30 en direct sur france
3 bourgogne et france 3 franche comté et
puis bien sûr la grande soirée
électorale dimanche prochain premier
tour des élections régionales merci à
tous merci eric et vive la vie politique
on va dire ça comme ça